اعرب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن
امله ان يصوت الشعب التركي له بكثافه وان
يحصل على رقم قياسي من الاصوات في جوله
الانتخابات الثانيه المقرره في 28 من مايو
ايار الجاري واكد اردوغان في تغريده ان
الشعب التركيه عبر بالفعل عن ارادته في
الجوله الاولى ومن تحالفه الاغلبيه منح
تحالفه الاغلبيه في البرلمان وضعف انه لا
يمكن الوثوق بمنافسه كمالك
الذي قال انه يمارس الضغط والترهيبه
والابتزازه ضد خصومه السياسيين
تصريحات اردو بعد يوم من اعلان مرشح
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الجوله الاولى سنا
نغام دعمه للرئيس التركي في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات المقرره الاحد
المقبل
اريد ان اشدد على اننا لم ندخل في مساومات
او ارتباطات او تعهدات او قدمنا مطالب
عبرنا عن المبادئ التي ندافع عنها وعن
خطوطنا الحمراء وعقدنا لقاءاتنا مع كلا
المرشحين بشكل يليق برجل دوله وباحترام
متبادل واتقدم بالشكر لهما ونتيجه لتلك
المفاوضات والاستشارات ووفقا للرسائل التي
تلقيناها من حاضنتنا الشعبيه نعلن دعمنا
لمرشح تحالف الجمهور الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه ندعو المقترعين
الذين صوتوا لنا في الجوله الاولى لدعم
السيد اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه
بدوره دعا رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري ومرشح
تحالف الشعب كمال كليش دار اوغلو تعش
الشعب التركيه للتصويت بكثافه في جوله
الاعاده للانتخابات الرئاسيه لحمايه
الاقتصاد من الانهيار حسب قمحه
في مقطع فيديو نشره على حسابه الرسمي في
موقع تويتر من تجاوز الليره التركيه حاجز
الثلاثين ليره مقابل الدولار الواحد في
حال فاز غريبه الرئيس التركي ومرشح تحالف
الجمهور رشاد رجب طيب اردوغان
لا يهم ان كنت تحبني ام لا لكن عليك ان
تقرر من اجل اقتصاد بلدك وتذكر انفازه
هؤلاء ستقفز الليره الى حد الثلاثين مقابل
الدولار ولا تنسى ان صوتك في هذه
الانتخابات ليس من اجلك شخص لكنك تصوت
لاجلك انت